welcome back to new rockstars it's the
boys underground boys only except for
uh the girl who's gonna join us in
hosting this show
and then the girls that act on the show
the boys and
the girls that are in my heart uh you
know who you are
and please respond to my letters this is
the boys underground the show
that dissects and reacts to amazon's the
boys
like we wish homelander would dissect
and uh appropriately react to his mommy
issues because
right now he's just hurting people we'll
be breaking down every episode of season
one of the boys here in this episode
of boys underground all the kills all
the thrills and
all the gills we're looking at you the
deep he's got those sensitive gills he
does not i looks like i'm rubbing my
nipples right now but
he's got kills that people jam their
hands into and he says no he doesn't
like that he doesn't
respond to the word no appropriately in
season one but he has boundaries so
maybe like homelander we can get him to
healthily process all of his issues with
the second season of the boys
set to release on september 4th in this
episode we're going to remind you what
happened in season one
we're gonna share some easter eggs and
things you might have missed in season
one
and we're going to talk about some of
the lingering questions heading into
season two
hopefully nobody will get laser eyed by
an infant
a lot of things can happen when you're
holding an infant uh they can puke on
you they can poop on you they can pee on
you
and you can recover from all of those
things but if an infant
blasts you with laser sight that's
basically it for you uh
you you will die that's my knowledge so
who's joining me
in the boys underground well with me to
share their thoughts on all things
vaught
our new rockstar's resident starlight
eric voss
president starlight there's so many
other members of the seven that i'm
probably more similar to
i disagree starlight is starlight is
beautiful
starlight is pure and starlight is a
good friend eric and what are you
beautiful pure good friend i always say
that uh
i i think you need different definitions
for all three of those things for them
to work for me
okay uh well fine if you say so it has
promised before it's not just
boys in the underground uh who could it
be
joining me she's high on compound v
she's a very talented lady give it up
for marina mastros
hi y'all i enjoy drugs yes all right
okay so let's before we all get too far
off the rails here let's go back and
recap what happened in season one a lot
has happened in the last year so where
did the boys leave off
quick spoiler warning for those of you
that have not yet watched a show that
came out in july of 2019
let's say you've been busy let's say
you've been traveling the world going
into crowded bars taking in music
concerts going to the movie theater
every night no you haven't
you haven't we've all been stuck inside
there's no excuse for why you haven't
watched the boys and i'm not yelling at
you because i'm angry
i'm yelling at you because i'm concerned
click on your little amazon
watch the show it's easy it's fun you
might learn a thing or two and you know
what
elizabeth's shoes in it and she's easy
on the eyes okay that's reason enough
all right so where were we
in season one well first things first we
meet the seven
this is the show's equivalent to the
justice league but they're run more like
a
a sports team by the shadowy corporation
vaught international they're like the
dallas cowboys of superheroes right
successful sure great stats fun to watch
a lot of championships but there's just
a lot of drug use and crime
underneath it's a murder so vaugh makes
deals
for their heroes to protect cities and
they also have ambitions to eventually
supplant
the military and replace the troops with
soups you see what i did there that's
fun i'm bringing rhymes to you no matter
what
they're willing to do anything to gain
power including having soups shoot down
planes
or blackmail politicians and as i've
always said on any show on new rockstars
network
uh you have to blackmail first then
shoot down the plane
if you shoot down the plane and then
attempt blackmail
uh you only accomplish one of those
goals that's that's all i'm gonna say
it's just murder it's just it's just
murder at that point it's charred
charred mail your chart remains male
that's dark i hope no one's lost anyone
in a
plane crash that watches this uh the
seven include
uh the wonder woman-esque maeve queen
maeve
the flash proxy a train aquaman
equivalent to deep
and their leader the superman adjacent
homelander i know what you're thinking
tommy that's only four
and they're called the seven we're gonna
get there okay we're gonna tell you who
rounds out the seven
there's also black noir right eric uh
who we haven't seen there's a
translucent who
gets killed off in an early episode of
the season and then and our new member
which tommy's going to talk about that's
right uh the eric voss of the seven
our newest member is actually who we're
introduced to
uh and that is starlight who is like
jubilee
if jubilee had legit powers q commenter
jubilee said omega mutant i know mega
mutant i tell you
i know but she's only on screen in the
movie for like one second
so we quickly discover that the seven
are not as they seem
from the outside they're narcissistic
they're corrupt
and they all get their powers from
covert experiments and a secret drug
compound v they're the new england
patriots they're not the cowboys they're
the patriots
all of their success is derived from
drug use yeah no tom brady grew hair
when he was 43.
that's what happens to men when they
turn 40 they grow more hair
anyway so the main action of the series
kicks off
uh pretty intensely when a train
accidentally murders the girlfriend of
our other audience surrogate
huey i mean he runs right through her
yes huey's chiding her about uh billy
joel which broke my heart because i love
billy joel and billy joel would never be
associated with that kind of violence
anyway huey teams up with vengeful
former government agent billy butcher to
get revenge billy reassembles his team
of ragtag former agents
the boys that's where the title comes
from and they begin the nasty business
of trying to undermine or kill all the
soups and
vaught itself along the way huey and
starlight
fall in love and we see a soup squish a
man's head like a grape during sex ah
depends on what your kink is either you
like traditional love
or you like grape squishy i like both at
the same time
anyway the boys are joined by their own
soup uh the x-23 like
kamiko homelander kills tons of people
including his lover and handler
madeleine stillwell
rip elizabeth shu you are a goddess i've
loved you since
picture is still alive just the
characters oh sorry yes
uh live live in peace elizabeth shoe
rip rattle and stillwell and by the way
elizabeth shoe made you live another 40
years
uh 35 of which we spent together in my
beautiful cottage in lake ontario
and in a final moment the rock guy sucks
it's actually revealed that homelander
had a child
with billy's ex-wife and that kid is
super powered
that's dysfunctional there's not enough
boxes uh
on the tv screen for that brady bunch
right there because half of the people
are getting lasered
so i think that about covers it guys did
i miss anything well yeah of course
there was a big uh flight 37
crash on that queen maven homelander
didn't do anything to help prevent or if
you could argue with led to
uh that seems to be a real big thing
with homelander and
plane crashes he's way too okay with
causing them
uh and it seems like that's something
that's gonna come back up you know it
was too big an event it
obviously wasn't one time it was
probably the most horrific thing to see
on screen
for me that year yes absolutely
homelanders saw the dark knight rises
and thought
bane crashed one plane
how do i go bigger i crushed two planes
with no survivors
so that's what he did uh all right so
this would not be a new rock stars video
if we did not have
sweet eric v compound v
i would say uh not compound v i would
say magnanimous v
eric voss pointing out some easter eggs
for us
going on a little easter icon things you
might have missed moments where don
cheeto might have said boom
you know maybe things like that eric
what do you got for us um
all right well tommy marina i'm uh gonna
just break down
ten cool new visual details i spotted
during my most recent re-watch
some of these are harder to find than
like the cameos and comic references
that are all over the place in the show
if you read the comics you're like oh
yeah that background signed or
oh yeah mother's milk's mug yeah that's
from the show but i'm gonna try to just
like talk about the stuff that's new
to the comic readers themselves are like
whoa that's freaking crazy and let's
start
with this fly a lot of you had seen this
there was uh this fly that kept buzzing
around randomly
and a bunch of shots so in episode four
it was when butcher gives that
hilarious spice girls pep talk uh in
penn station
uh there's a right when he says there's
a fly that
buzzes around in frame and there's a one
that shows up again in episode five
when starlight's talking to the kids at
that bible expo yeah and then in that
same episode when he was talking about
god
uh in that episode um it seems
it's got to be deliberate because like
why would they use these takes well
the showrunner eric crippy was uh asked
about it and he claimed that the flies
were just happy accidents and they
decided to leave it in
uh to like show the characters moral
corruption i call
[ __ ] guys you think this is more
breaking bad
i think yeah uh and as we'll get to
later in this list there are
some breaking bad uh parallels here
george mastros
is a writer on the show uh on both shows
so like i think there's definitely a
parallel it's a big mystery comic
readers are even kind of stumped by this
one there is a character named swatto
who speaks buzz noises but
in the comics he's like a normal sized
human something that maybe the show
you know since it's made a ton of
changes to the comics might be like
changing swatto
to be like an ant-man type shrinking
soup who's like spying on the boys in
this moment um
i i think it's gonna be even uh it's
gonna go even deeper than that
maybe it was an accident but they're
gonna keep bringing it back
it's like a cool like breaking bad style
like expression of their
of their moral decay as it was in that
uh great ryan johnson directed episode
of breaking bad
um we'll see we'll see but i'm i'm we'll
talk more about it this episode
uh all right second second big detail
that i uh spotted
so when butcher first recruits huey he
says the line
were you she wasn't in the street she
was one step off [ __ ] good
and that is almost exactly what huey
said when he and his dad were watching a
train's press conference
when he was like explaining the incident
she was a half step
off the curb uh and that could imply
there's a very good chance that butcher
had bugged huey's home in workplace
before recruiting him
and he was now using his exact words as
a way to be like whoa how does this guy
know exactly how i feel now it could be
it's just like good writing and he's
that good at knowing exactly how to
empathize with huey
in that moment yeah but in the context
of the scene in that store he's talking
about the nanny cam
teddy bear right there which shows up
later in the season so it's probably
butcher is signaling to him like hey
i've been i've been keeping an eye on
you
i've been keeping an eye on you eric i
look around your apartment
everything is bugged baby groot you're
burning later
also in episode one huey sees a dog toy
in butcher's back seat a lot of you guys
caught this
um he says that he doesn't have a dog
but in the comics butcher does have a
bulldog named terror
and he shows up actually in one of
butcher's flashbacks later on in episode
four
and uh we will be seeing more of terror
this upcoming season so it was a fun day
not there um so one of my favorite
details in episode three billy butcher
tells mother's milk that uh when they're
in that pack and go rental truck to spy
on a train and pop claws apartment
that the truck that they're in isn't
conspicuous and he says
i think a big black van with flowers on
the side is conspicuous this is just
another truck on the street
and then later in episode eight outside
the motel where the boys are hiding
the van that the swat officers hide in
is of course a black van with flowers
on the side i did notice that yeah that
was that was a really fun call back
there it's like of course of course the
idiot swat teams that's
that's what they would use uh and
butcher called it so in episode four
uh there's a really cool detail that i
love from the actor here
when homelander lands on the hijacked
flight 37 and he's like calling out to
the people his voice is a bit raspy at
first and then it adjusts to normal
as he's catching his breath it's all
safe you're all gonna be fine
come on now you guys anthony starr
actually does this pretty much every
time homelander lands after flying
it's his lungs and vocal cords adjusting
from the abrupt
shift in altitude that's what you would
do because like the air pressure
is different it would take your your
lungs even if your soup uh moment to
just adjust as you're talking
and uh he also does this in episode
three at the uh at the race at the arena
you can see his voice is a bit raspy and
a couple moments later it adjusts
sorry i'm late you got room for one more
it's here for my boy a train
all right and then the weirdest part is
when he just like
sucks up an entire balloon of helium and
does like a really high voice
that part was weird that was crazy a bit
out of nowhere
some might say okay now this is one of
my favorite details that uh that we
spotted
in episode four when a butcher mother's
milk and frenchy are in new york's penn
station
near the platforms the a-line the b-line
the c-line when camiko jumps on the
track and runs into a train
a train is running on the a line where
new york's a
train runs
[Music]
yeah that is i like that's cute that's a
cute fun little
fun little set placement it's cute it's
a
little
cute little wink cute little wink um and
then moving on to our list uh this is
a really really fun detail when
homelander is
touring the house he grew up in in
episode six which of course is not his
real house it's just for the cameras
there's a moment
where the camera frames him chuckling in
front of one of the model planes that
are scattered all over the house
that plane's nose is tilted downward
this is
you know two episodes after he let the
plane go down
and of course go down
um but just that little lat that little
chuckle just sells his lack of a soul
and if you keep an eye on homeland
throughout the season all kinds of like
dark demonic imagery surrounds him in
the background like in episode two when
he's talking to frenchie
in the alley uh behind him there's
graffiti of an upside down cross
with 666 on it so it's just like signals
that this guy is kind of an antichrist
figure
yeah that's like my number one fear yeah
yeah
like everyone kind of knows it but
they're too afraid to say or stop them
right and then episode 8 homelander
kills all the terrorists in the
warehouse
for the troops and then uh there's
another example this
graffiti in arabic on the side of the
building right behind him right when he
says god bless america that graffiti in
arabic translates to
homelander is racist which is so great
that they put that in there relevant
guys relevant
relevant now this is a fun detail that
connects the beginning of the season to
the end of the season when queen maeve
and episode 8 is telling starlight she's
you know coming clean about the truth of
her broken arm and she says that
you know the radius never healed
straight she really did break every bone
in her right arm when she was trying to
stop a bus from falling
when you go back to look at the opening
montage in episode one you can see a
more jaded older mave stopping the truck
with her back
defusing the impact and it ends up being
kind of less heroic right she smashes
through the truck and she has to beat up
all the guys
inside it like shielding it from
onlookers
seeing her as a hero figure because she
learned when she was starlight's age
when she does that she's going to hurt
herself so unfortunately she has to
be a more jaded you know less camera
friendly
hero by doing it this way so some nice
continuity there
um and then i mentioned the the breaking
bad homages
um so yeah george mastros is a writer on
the show and there's a bloody cleanup
that opens episode three right after
they blow up translucent
um which definitely parallels jesse and
walt cleaning up that melted body in
season one
in the house um and of course giancarlo
esposito gustavo frank from breaking bad
and better girl saul he plays
vaught-head mr edgar
and in episode eight he says someone
needs to run this [ __ ] show when i move
to belize and in breaking bad with you
know saul goodman
uh he says moving to belize as a
euphemism for
croaking for getting killed yes have you
given any thought to um
sending him on a trip to belize a lot of
really cool parallels obviously there's
a lot more stuff i was just trying to go
for
some of the more favorite easter eggs
but uh i look
forward to seeing more in season two yes
uh
i like it my basket is full of easter
eggs now eric
who and uh tommy before we continue with
the rest of the episode we want to thank
some people who helped us make it this
episode of the boys underground is
brought to you by helix sleep
if you're anything like me sleep has
been a little tougher lately it's not
like i'm homeland or i bet that
psychopath sleeps like a baby no matter
how many people he's killed that day me
i'm tossing and turning all night like i
missed one easter egg which happens
pretty much every video i do
helix sleep makes personalized
mattresses made right here in america
and shipped straight to your door with
free
no contact delivery free returns and a
100 night sleep trial
to choose a mattress helix made a quiz
that takes just two minutes to complete
and it matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you
if you like a mattress that's really
soft or firm or if you sleep on your
side or your back or your stomach or if
you sleep really hot or
really cold weirdly with helix there's a
specific mattress for each and
every person's unique taste i took the
quiz and i ended up getting matched with
the
luxe dusk helix mattress because you
know i'm goldilocks i like something
that's just in the middle medium and i
toss and i turn all night because
goldilocks
is eating too much porridge and that's
gonna keep you up with a full belly
just go to helixleep.com underground
take their
two-minute sleep quiz and they will
match you to a customized mattress that
will give you the best sleep of your
life
helix sleep was awarded the number one
best overall mattress pick of 2019 by gq
and wired magazine
they have a 10 year warranty and you get
to try it out for a hundred nights
risk-free
they even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you're gonna love it
helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners
at helix sleep dot com slash underground
that's helix h-e-l-i-x
sleep.com underground for over 200 off
guys now it's time for some questions uh
that i have from last season that i feel
have not been
answered by the show uh this show has
answered a lot of questions very well
the show the boys with a much higher
budget has failed to
uh satisfy my curiosity which some say
is unhealthy uh so let's hope our
answers don't sound really dumb
uh when season two comes out and uh if
they do we'll just scrub this from the
internet like all my sketch comedy
prior to 2015 because every character is
problematic
uh all right so
my first question for you guys is what
exactly happened to butcher's wife
becca becca butcher it was interesting
right because uh in the comics
the is completely different what
happened to her in the show the fact
that she's still alive and she had
homelanders kid
is like a huge game changer i guess the
question is like
uh you know butcher did say he he raped
her and she went missing
or he killed her it's all the same to me
like in his mind that's
they're both equal evils um so i think
in butcher's mind it's
it's all the same or you could argue
even worse that
that she has uh his kid but as to what
happened like i don't know if
uh obviously homeland or this is news to
him
i mean what do you think she was doing
all that time marina i would this i'm
still kind of scratching my head
i mean if it were me and i would want to
protect
well the kid right especially if he has
superpowers
and i would train i i think this is what
she's been doing this whole time
is training this little super soldier
right
and the whole time she raises him she's
like look your dad is a piece of
[ __ ] all right and when you get older
you're gonna have to murder him right
and so you just prepare him from
birth to like be this have you guys seen
the hannah
yes it's kind of like that like she just
is off in the woods except it's like the
suburbs
and she's just like raising this
superhero to like actually be a
superhero and take out
you know his dad and maybe she doesn't
tell him that like he's his dad but
she's like listen there's this bad dude
that you're gonna have to fight one day
and this is the way that it is
if it were me i would like be personally
raising my own little like
mini army super army oh my god
she's like obi-wan kenobi and the kid is
like luke yeah and they're training him
to fight darth vader
oh my god the connections that's a
little easter egg from me
okay so question two who is gonna be
more of a threat
uh in season two homelander or
stormfront
i think it's interesting uh homelander
the fact that he has a kid now
he kind of has something to lose in a
weird way whereas the fact that
stormfront has like a social media army
that is watching live all these behind
the scenes
things like that's a threat that i feel
like homelander doesn't know how to
confront
right okay so at the end of the season
he gets rid of his only vulnerability
which
everybody thought was still well but
then you know he lasers her brain
which honestly she deserved um
and then everybody kind of or at least
when i was watching it i was like okay
like
now he has no vulnerabilities but you're
right
now that he knows he has a son i feel
like he's gonna be one of those
bad characters who thinks that this is
the thing that's gonna
change him and now he can become
like a family guy and a good person and
so this is the thing that he's wanted
this whole time and
she can use that against him when we
finally thought like okay there now he
has nothing left to lose but you're
right he actually does
all right yeah maybe she'll start a
campaign to cancel homelander
yeah yeah get all her followers on board
uh all right so we've spoken of the fly
uh and the mystery around the fly do you
guys think the fly's coming back in
season two
um it's gonna come back but only when
homelander is diagnosed with cancer
how powerful i mean
i hope it comes back i hope it turns
into something more than just an
accident because like if not like eric
kripke must realize
what an opportunity has on his hand like
this is something that like
could be the first like organic natural
easter egg
uh fan theory that just becomes adopted
into the canon of the show
like turn a turn make it a true happy
accident not just a thematic one but
like
make that fly top build on the show i
want that fly in the opening credits
and he's going to be he's gonna get an
executive producer credit
i i think the fly uh will
land on the eyeball of queen maeve just
as anthony hopkins enters the scene and
says that's enough maeve
and reveals that this has all been a
tie-in to westworld
and that these superhero characters are
all hosts
in a superhero like world on westworld
i'm just kidding
do not reply in the comments that that's
crazy i know it's crazy
everything i say is crazy i read at a
fourth grade level
all right will the seven turn on
starlight and haven't they already
turned on starlight or in some ways
hasn't she turned on them
what's gonna happen with starlight in
season two i think i mean they should
right
like if we're everybody else maybe only
maeve is on her side yeah
we might see a thing where like uh the
seven is no longer
it might seem like a disillusion of the
seven because it seems like there's too
many conflict points on the inside
the fact that deep has just gone crazy
uh i mean
they already had absolute members we're
gonna see some conflicts with black noir
that's gonna be an interesting thing so
you might see you know kind of like how
at the beginning of game of thrones
there are certain alliances but they're
really just clearly temporary
yeah i think that's gonna collapse and
you're gonna see like a lot of
splintering off and you might see that
same thing happen on the boys as well
like i can imagine uh like billy butcher
the fact that like he his wife is still
alive he could have like a temporary
alliance with homeland or
to bring down stormfront you know in the
interest of helping protect becca
sure all right last question uh
what's going on with my guy black noir i
think he's a guy
do we know if he's a guy i have no idea
yeah so
i'm kind of like foot and mouth right
now because there's uh there's something
very interesting that happens with black
noir in the comics and kind of readers
know what it is
don't spoil it in the comments um but
it's it's a very
interesting plot development and i'm
it's kind of hard to talk about the
character even without even
starting to go down this path i just
hope that like
they keep us surprised further from the
from the comics i hope they don't do
exactly what's in the comics
just because the show so far has done
such a good job uh surprising even comic
readers
and uh and you know subverting the
expectations in good ways
i i haven't read the comics so to me i
think the surprise is that um
black noir takes his helmet off and he's
actually just batman but like no
but not a batman that we recognize like
we're supposed to recognize who this
guy's face is and like
oh oh it's the batman in the show no no
he has his
he still has his mask on and he's like
he's still in costume
he has another cowl yeah he just reveals
another mask
like under armour yeah yeah yeah
i i like that all right well needless to
say it appears as though
black noir is going to play a more uh a
prominent role this season and we're
going to learn more about that
character okay so now we've come to the
point
in the show that we've we've talked
enough about the living
we've talked enough about people we were
surprised to learn are alive
let's now talk about the people we can
confirm are definitely dead
marina walk us through the kill count on
season one of the boys please
absolutely there's nothing i love more
than murder as everybody knows yes
yes absolutely uh so there was a whole
lot of murder in the first season
which you know so i was on board i was
like you know
eating popcorn like yeah i get them uh
cheering
everybody around me was crying it was
great and the whole first season we
counted
all of it every murder so starting with
the people who didn't kill
anybody and going to the most the people
who murdered the most people
um at least not on screen right so we're
we're talking about on-screen stuff
so starting off with zero is the deep
starlight black noir mother's milk and
frenchie so all of those people have
zero kill count unless you count uh the
dolphin that the deep
yeah shitley kills i mean dolphins are
almost as smart as people or smarter
guys i like to think
me too i think so i think that counts
we'll give him one we'll give him one
and then
blackmore is about to kill a lot more so
we'll we'll see more on screen kills
from him
okay and then one for pop claw which was
i screamed i was like that is so
funny she like killed him with her ass
talk about [ __ ]
guys yes it was so good
and also one um it one for maeve she
killed that hijacker on the plane
uh oh that's right yeah and then you
know we can like argue
as to whether like she counts as also
killing all those people on the plane
but it was kind of already happening
already but this is just on screen like
she definitely did it
so for two a train we have a train
um so atrium killed huey's girlfriend
and he killed
hop claw right
oh he's a real lady killer
great and then also two for huey so he
blows up transparent which reminded me a
lot of blade
actually wesley snipes when he they
stick all the little thingies in him and
he's like pull
up and then just explode uh and he also
just kills like a random like
nameless along the way as well
um and kimiko has four
and so she has the she kills the three
goons that are keeping her captive
um and then that one that one guy
shoots himself so that she won't that's
right i had a chance to
which i thought was hilarious
surprisingly enough
billy butcher also only has four um so
he kills
three goons um with the laser baby and
that's right yeah that was awesome uh
very uh incredibles very all uh
the incredibles two when the baby gets
late oh yeah
yeah you know they don't commit murder
because it's a disney show but you know
that raccoon almost got it
almost got the laser uh and then he also
kills
mesmer and uh so haley joel osment
who did a great job but hayley was so
good
yeah he took him out hard that that was
brutal i was so happy to see him
like getting work and like doing like
acting and
i was just like oh boy get it and but
then he died
we have five for nakib who is the soup
terrorist
yep and so he takes out a bunch of army
guys and
skipping from number five i mean some so
kill count of five
we go we jump all the way to 143
for homelander yep uh so he threw
he throws one bad guy in the air uh he
killed six people on the planet on that
private plane um he indiana jones is the
guy
you know that's right yeah almost rips
out his heart and does the like
he kills two hijackers on the plane uh
he goes of course 123 people on the
plane and you know what i think that's
right
so let's i'm gonna give all full credit
to
homelander on that because they've tried
to convince him yeah she wanted to
she wouldn't even save like at least
some of them and and
he's like no witnesses yeah so i'm gonna
give all those to him
um give them because it's something good
to have right
yes yes uh he also kills nine more goons
and then of course he kills stillwell by
lasering her
through the eyeballs which was very
oddly
satisfying to watch or is that just me
because i'm a weirdo
i to me i kind of felt like uh we've
already seen you kill so many
nah man i was like she has this comment
she has a comment
oh god it's just like how many people
are you gonna kill man it's just like
desensitized almost
i am gonna add at least for now
another uh another count to
billy because oh he blows up a baby
that's right it wasn't clear it wasn't
on screen but i think you're right i
think it's implied that that baby was in
the next room
the baby was in the room and oh you're
talking oh i know what you're saying
yeah yeah i think i don't i don't see
how that baby survived i don't know
where it is
you're right it was literally in the
corner of the room that they were in and
he
and let me tell you can i just tell
everybody watching that i watched this
whole season and i was on board i was
like yes this is a good show i'm
i'm about it i love murder then this
mother
blew up a baby and i was like
i'm out i want this character to die i
don't give a [ __ ] about this character
anymore
like homelander needs to turn around and
murder billy butcher for blowing up a
baby like
he cannot i'm gonna watch season two i'm
gonna watch it
and over the course of this you two
tommy and eric you
are gonna watch me watch the billy
butcher try to
earn back my my affection because
as far as i'm concerned he can
walk off a cliff because he blew up a
baby
tough to come back from that tough to
come back
politically yeah that'd be tough for him
to run for office for sure but not
unprecedented
not not unheard of if he's from florida
he could probably be a congressman
uh no offense eric boy it's gonna be
hard to do
let me tell you all right that will be
our challenge for for this upcoming
season
can billy butcher win back marina's
heart well we hope to find out guys
that's our show
so great to chat with you eric and
marina tune in every week for our
reactions to the latest the boys episode
including next week where we'll be
covering the first three episodes
they're all dropping at one time on
september 4th
and remember uh please follow me at
tommy bechtold follow eric voss
at ea voss follow marina at marina
mastros
and follow new rockstars on socials and
subscribe here on youtube
to get too much information about all of
the stuff
you care about let's hear it for the
boys and the girls
and everyone the people thank you have a
good night
[Music]
you